mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
solve for the value of x in the
following equation
the first term is x the second term is x
divided by one plus two the third term
is x divided by one plus two plus three
this pattern continues until the final
term which is x divided by one plus two
plus so on all the way up to four
thousand forty-one
the entire sum is equal to four thousand
forty-one
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
to solve this problem i will first
review triangular numbers then i will go
over a partial fraction decomposition
and then we will solve the problem
let's get started with triangular
numbers
suppose you want the sum of one plus two
plus three and so on all the way up to n
this is exactly equal to the number of
dots in this equilateral triangle
arrangement
for this reason each such number is
known as a triangular number and is
denoted as tn
we can solve a formula for tn in terms
of n in the following clever way
we'll first arrange the dots in a right
triangle
we will then add a copy of tn to itself
we will then rotate this triangular grid
as shown which will be equivalent to
taking the sum in descending order going
from n to 1.
we can then combine the two sums
together
notice that each row has an interesting
and constant sum
the first row is equal to one plus n
which is equal to n plus one
the second row is also equal to n plus
one because we pair two with n minus one
every single row will have a constant
sum that's equal to n plus one
this is visualized in the following
rectangular grid
every single row has a value of n plus
one dots and there are a total of n rows
therefore two times t n is equal to n
multiplied by n plus one
we can divide both sides of this
equation by two to get the famous
formula that t n is equal to n
multiplied by n plus one all over two
let's now go over a partial fraction
decomposition
suppose we have the fraction one divided
by n multiplied by n plus one
we want to write this in the following
expansion so one fraction will be a over
n
and the other fraction will be some
other number b over n plus one
to solve for the values of a and b we'll
multiply both sides by n multiplied by n
plus one
we'll then distribute this
in the first fraction the n's cancel out
and in the second fraction the n plus
ones cancel out
we now have this equation we'll
distribute the a term and then we'll
collect the n terms
we'll factor an n to get n multiplied by
a plus b
on the left hand side we have 1 which is
equal to 1 plus n times 0.
we can now equate coefficients of the
constant term to get that a is equal to
1.
we then equate the coefficients on the n
term so we get a plus b is equal to zero
since we know that a is equal to one we
have one plus b is equal to zero which
means b is equal to negative one
we've thus solved for the values of a
and b
so the partial fraction decomposition
will be equal to one over n plus
negative one over n plus one
and we can rewrite the second term as
minus one over n plus one
so now let's solve the problem
the first thing we'll do is we'll notice
that each of the numerators has an x so
we'll factor out an x term from every
single one of these fractions
next we'll see that this denominator is
1 plus 2 and we'll use the formula for
triangular numbers
this will be equal to 2 multiplied by 3
over 2.
we'll substitute that into the
denominator
the third term will be t3 which is equal
to 3 times 4 over 2.
we substitute that in
the final term will be equal to t of
4041 and we'll substitute that in
we then have 1 over tn for each of these
fractions so we'll take the reciprocal
so this will bring the two to the
numerator of each of these fractions
now we'll just clean up this equation a
little bit and we'll notice that the
first term does not look like any of the
other terms so let's bring it into the
same sort of form
so 1 is equal to 2 over 2 and 2 is equal
to 1 times 2.
so now every single term in this sum has
the same sort of form
from here we can factor out a 2 from
every single numerator
we will now look at the first fraction
we'll see we have 1 divided by 1
multiplied by 2 and we'll use our
partial fraction decomposition
this will be equal to 1 over 1 minus 1
over 2.
the second fraction we can use the same
formula
we get one over two minus one over three
we do the same thing for the third
fraction we get one over three minus one
over four and we continue to the very
last fraction
now when we want to evaluate the sum we
notice an interesting pairing
negative one-half plus one-half is equal
to zero
then we consider these pair of terms
negative one over three plus one over
three is equal to zero
and every such term will pair like this
so we're going to cancel out all of
these terms in the middle
this is similar to a retracting
telescope where only the very beginning
and the very end survives
for this reason this type of sum is
known as a telescoping sum
so all of these middle terms will vanish
now one over one is equal to 4042 over
4042 this will allow us to evaluate this
subtraction a little bit easier so this
will be equal to 4041 over 4042
we now have a simple equation
we multiply both sides by the reciprocal
of 4041 over 4042
and then we multiply both sides of the
equation by 1 over 2.
so we simply need to simplify this
4041 will cancel out and then we have
4042 divided by two which is equal to
two thousand twenty one
and that's the answer to the problem
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
[Music]
you